the opening trap for saw five is the
pendulum the imitation jigsaw trap
created by mark hoffman to execute his
sister's killer like many jigsaw traps
hoffman would take inspiration from a
historical torture device and add a
modern element using machinery there's
some debate as to whether or not the
pendulum was actually used to scare or
torture prisoners of the spanish
inquisition in the 18th century but we
can say with certainty that it was used
by edgar allan poe in his fictional
story the pit and the pendulum
in fact almost all of the traps in saw
five have ties to uncivilized methods of
enforcing justice
and the end of the movie would bring the
connection to the pit in the pendulum
back front and center so stick around to
the end of this video to find out why
welcome back to things you missed and
welcome back to my saw series
if you want to see all 171 things you
missed in saws 1 through 4
click here saw 5 would continue the
tradition of not bringing in anyone with
any experience directing a major studio
movie by hiring the production designer
of the last three movies david hackl
as you might expect this resulted in a
lot of easter eggs hidden in the actual
set maybe more than ever before so let's
take a look at some things you missed
after the introduction with the pendulum
trap were finally shown in the aftermath
of the gideon meadpacking plan games of
saws 3 and 4.
agent strom ends up locked in the
operation room and is only able to find
his way out with the aid of some
glow-in-the-dark paint pointing out a
secret door this is kind of a
combination of the glow-in-the-dark
paint illuminating the breakable wall in
saw one and the cracks at the edge of
the trap door revealing an exit in saw
too
strom then finds himself in the water
cube trap and he has to use the only
thing he has on him his pen
to perform a trachectomy this was really
well set up in saw4 where strom was
constantly seen fidgeting with the
patent to hoffman's surprise he makes it
out of the building alive and on the
ambulance is what i believe is the first
example where we clearly see the state
license plates and the nickname of the
state is
the fair weather state throughout the
series i've talked about how i think saw
takes place in a fictional state in the
northeast united states and the plate
does kind of look like new jersey
additionally when we see the inside of
the fbi headquarters the words eastern
surveillance are written on a window as
if to suggest that jigsaw city is on the
east coast and a line from brit
stevenson later on could be alluding to
the fact that she works nearby
in new york city no i'm not
i build condos in one of the most
densely populated cities in the country
the fbi has offices in both newark and
new york and agent strom's phone number
has a 2-1-2 area code meaning he could
be from the nearby city of new york
as jill tuck waits to meet with her
ex-husband's executor a woman in the
waiting room reads a magazine about john
kramer with articles written by elise
lam
and nate richmond both of which are
easter eggs for crew members on saw five
nate richmond was a production assistant
and elise lam was the art director
as far as characters who never appear on
screen elise's is one of the biggest
because she not only wrote this magazine
article but also the newspaper article
announcing jigsaw's death the article
about the death of hoffman's sister
another article about angelina's murder
and one about the death of her killer
seth baxter but there are a couple
unseen easter egg characters that are
even more interesting than elise
you may remember sean schofield the
graphic designer who put his name on the
fingerprint analysis report in saw
four for saw five he was promoted to
first assistant art director so he got
to put his name in there even more
he seems to have helped prepare these
probable victim binders along with
stephanie woolishen
in the real world stephanie is a
production assistant but in the saw
world she's an fbi
agent living a double life as an
investigative journalist for the herald
the same newspaper that charles salaman
also writes for i'm an investigative
journalist
for the herald i can't imagine the fbi
is too happy about one of their agents
publishing
information about the same cases that
they're investigating for a public
newspaper but for our purposes
stephanie's information answers a big
question about the link between john
kramer and hoffman
how did jon find out about hoffman
before the pendulum if the pendulum was
hoffman's first attempt at a trap
it seems that before killing angelina
seth baxter was involved in a drug
charge so he probably had ties to jill's
drug clinic like many of jigsaw's
victims did
so jon would have been watching seth
around the time that he took out
hoffman's sister and when seth went to
prison for it jon switched his focus to
hoffman the lord you can discover in the
newspapers in the series is just so
interesting to me for some reason i
guess i feel like i'm getting extra
content somehow for example
sean schofield may have also had a
second job outside of the fbi
though it's kind of hard to tell on this
one it might say sean medfield we'll
have to revisit this if they ever
released the movies in 4k
or we could just not do that because no
one cares
i like how there's a level of
consistency when building the saw world
when strom is clicking through the
headlines the publications are many of
the same ones we've seen in previous
movies
it's also amazing how so many of these
jigsaw articles all use the same picture
which is really just a screenshot from
saw one heck i haven't used it in my
things you missed thumbnail
it's a good picture billy should make it
his twitter avatar he'd fit right in on
that website considering he's a puppet
when jill watches the tape left behind
for her by john you can tell it was made
in the operating room from saw three
while jon still has his hair but does
not have the bruises given to him by
matthews anymore which means he probably
recorded this shortly before the gideon
meat packing plant games of 2006.
this is important because it shows us
how late in his life jon began to have
remorse about the way his marriage ended
with the discovery of jon's body a
ceremony is held at the police station
to honor the fallen officers in his case
and promote hoffman to deputy lieutenant
but today i'd like to offer a special
honor to the detective
who's been on this case right from the
beginning wait hold on if you're
honoring
hoffman for being there from the
beginning what about fisk according to
the fbi's records fisk has actually been
on the task force longer than hoffman i
mean i know hoffman probably gets some
credit for saving that girl but as far
as we know fisk has a much cleaner
record than hoffman he doesn't even get
honored at all he just has to sit there
hashtag justice for fisk
also we get our first look at pamela
jenkins who would play a bigger role but
not until the next movie
foreshadowing when hoffman gives his
speech he talks about cherishing life
and bringing justice which could be what
you want to hear from your new
lieutenant but also happens to be
jigsaw's motto and hoffman would be the
one to carry out jigsaw's work
justice would be the key theme in the
main game of saw five and each trap was
carefully chosen to be symbolic of this
[Music]
idea
strom or as those close to him call him
peter is ordered off the jigsaw case by
his superior j jonah jameson
and hoffman begins leaving breadcrumbs
to make agent jameson i mean
eriksen put the pieces together that
maybe peter is spider-man
i mean jigsaw hoffman goes back to his
new lair to check on the next game and
we see how much he's learned from jigsaw
based on the way he decorates the plays
the anatomical human drawings call back
to the diagrams of the operation room
one of them is a copy of the vascular
system diagram from the spike trap in
soft 4.
the miniature version of the game was
also used by jon to plot out the details
of the bathroom game this game would be
known as the fatal fives trial and
because it was being held this time by
hoffman
a police officer who was obsessed with
justice after feeling his sister's
killer was not properly punished each
trap resembles an old outdated criminal
execution method and yes to be entirely
clear
this game was mapped out by jon but
hoffman was still the one to put
everything into motion so i think the
symbolism is still valid
the first room is an update on a device
tracing back to france during the times
of the french revolution the guillotine
was used to behead its victims but this
version implemented a system of tension
wires to force the participants to all
work together in order for them to
survive
instead of the typical shape for a
guillotine these blades all have a
v-shape which may be on purpose to stay
on theme with the roman numeral
representing the fifth movie
there are also five participants in this
game and i don't think that's an
accident
the second room requires victims to find
keys that give them access to these
safety chambers the name of the game is
inclusion there aren't enough chambers
to protect everybody so in order for
everyone to survive
someone would have had to invite another
into their chamber the salem witch
trials were a series of hearings that
outcast supposed witches from society in
the 1600s and like the unlucky loser who
was outcast in this room
they would meet a fiery fate i guess
this is saw five's pig that in the sense
that
it's pretty metal
yeah it is actually the third room
contained the electric bathtub which
represented another american execution
method the electric chair which was
created in the 1880s in buffalo new york
not too far away from where i think saw
takes place
again this one was designed for each of
the five of them to work together by
dividing up the voltage
rather than having one person take on
the full shock the last room represents
human sacrifice which i don't think we
can trace back to one specific era or
culture but again is designed for them
to work together by each sacrificing a
smaller amount of blood of course that
doesn't happen because there are only
two of them left at this point so here's
what i would have done
they had to fill this beaker up with
blood to a certain point in order to win
the game
there is a grate blocking the way so you
can't just drop stuff directly in the
beaker it has to be liquid
the door to the bathtub room was still
open after they cleared it so i would
take off my shirt dip it in the tub
until it's soaking wet and then ball it
up and squeeze
out the water above the beaker they
probably could have filled it up most of
the way like that
it's not until the end that they realize
what jigsaw was trying to tell them from
the beginning that they need to work
together
today this singular way of thinking will
be
put to the test today five will become
one
with a common goal of survival but while
hoffman executes the fatal fives game
strom follows the trail of hoffman in
one scene at the fbi headquarters we
actually see somebody studying audio
waveforms something that would come back
in the next movie there's also a name
randomly written on an fbi bulletin
board
tom vancellides he's the assistant
production manager on saw5 the police
station also has another crew reference
easter egg a box in the background here
contains the name soren poppis
who is the first assistant art director
as strom gets closer and closer to
discovering the truth about hoffman
we learn more and more about hoffman's
past and how he came to be involved with
the jigsaw it starts after he conducted
the pendulum trap one day at its
apartment complex when he bumps into
this stereotypical girl who probably
watches my videos and follows his
journey through the building he hears
what he thinks is a dispute and
approaches with his gun out it turns out
to be only this lady with her dog but i
think this scene does a good job of
illustrating what kind of cop hoffman is
this trait would be explored again in
saw seven yeah i prefer to call it saw7
because it's very difficult to watch it
in 3d anymore and also it's not the
final chapter anymore so
i don't call it that either finally he
gets to the elevator where he's got to
get out of the way of this lady and
these dudes who are probably on their
way to go meet up with found flicks at
the papa roach concert so it ends up
just being hoffman and jon in the
elevator
and since the scene takes place shortly
before the events of saw one john is
seen wearing the leather gloves that
were a big part of the first movie but
weren't really used in the bausman films
some say these gloves
are an homage to italian horror director
dario argento who has a movie called
deep red where the bad guy has these
leather gloves i mean i guess it could
be an intentional reference but it could
just as easily be
not that he wakes up in john's workshop
in this
spectacularly uncreative trap but one
thing i did notice was an early version
of the death collar from saw three in
that movie amanda claims that she built
the collar so maybe she physically built
it off of one of john's prototype
designs
when jon details the rules of the game
to hoffman he does so through the
reflection of a mirror
i'm the man you call jake could he be
doing this because he's looking into the
past
looking back at the rear view of the old
hoffman who has not yet been reborn as a
disciple of jigsaw is that too deep for
a saw movie
maybe maybe not also in this workshop i
spotted one of those chinese figurines
from beside john's deathbed in saw 3 and
the new year's festival in saw 4.
strom would continue to go through old
files to dig out more and more about
mark hoffman's past where he would page
past a curious detail
that could have changed the context of
crimes that took place all the way back
in the first saw film
as strom goes through the old case files
from the razer wire traps victim paul
leahy you may notice that detective
hoffman was actually the lead
investigator on it when we see that
crime scene back in the first movie it's
sing
tap and carry who has not yet been
promoted to detective there's no sign of
hoffman at all
i don't know if that means he had
already investigated it and these other
guys were coming to take a second look
or if he was calling the shots and asked
sing and tap to make their own
assessment perhaps to lead them down the
path to jigsaw with a plan to take them
out
the files seen earlier on list hoffman
and tap and sing as investigators on the
case and it seems to be the first jigsaw
case any of them worked on from what we
can see there though i should add that
there are other jigsaw murders that
aren't listed here or shown in any movie
but i'm not going to talk about that in
this
video we'll probably never solve the
mystery of hoffman's involvement in the
pauley case saw five also has another
ambiguous question which comes up when
jill tuck meets with erickson at the fbi
headquarters claiming that she believes
the bureau is following her
i think it's the agent who interrogated
me aiden strong the strange thing is
we never see this happen in fact we see
strom laser focused on investigating
hoffman paying no attention to jill
i guess it is possible that she was told
to do this by jon as part of his
instructions for her after his death but
i've come to think that there is another
possibility
in six we see that she has made contact
with hoffman who is actively trying to
get rid of strom and make him look like
the unknown accomplice
i think there's a possibility that
hoffman instructed jill to bring up
these concerns with eriksen maybe he
even threatened her to
get what he wants i don't see any other
reason for her to go to him unless she's
just trying to get a job at the daily
bugle
are you serious maybe it was all part of
hoffman's plan to frame special agent
strong
he does so by leaving strom's phone in
his lair at the catacombs where the
fiendish fives game took place
okay not the fiendish five the fatal
five that's what they're called
you know that fingus racka magookas had
a lot of nice pictures but
way too many big boys so he led j jonah
jameson to believe that strom was guilty
while leading strom to a seemingly
inconspicuous house a house that is the
last house on the left side of its
streets
with a light on the left and a storage
area on the right a house with a small
door
underneath the stairs a house whose
walls have a very familiar layout
could this location be the infamous
nerve gas house which was the venue of
the main game seen in saw two
it's definitely very similar in layout
right down to the room that contained
the safe with a trap door in the same
spot leading down to the underground
tunnel network which appears to be the
very same tunnel network that contains
the bathroom
judging by the inclusion of this sliding
door we know that john was a civil
engineer once involved in a major
housing project and he does have access
to multiple properties
in saw two we see him utilize both the
nerve gas house and the fake out house
with a seemingly similar layout
we also know that the project was
supposed to provide housing to 40
low-income families so it seems
reasonable that each of these units was
based on the same design
and they may have each had the same
layout i have to admit it doesn't really
make sense for john or hoffman to pull
off a major renovation of the
dilapidated nerve gas house just for
this one small moment i mean i'm not
really even sure that they could fix up
the house in such a short time frame
especially given all that they
accomplished between october 2005
and april 2006 and saw five takes place
not too long after
most likely in july 2006 maybe these
houses were all placed on a grid so that
there were several houses on the left
side of their respective streets that
would put the hoffman house in the same
neighborhood as the nerve gas house and
the fake out house which would make it
plausible that it could be connected to
the same tunnel network that contains
both the bathroom
and the glass coffin room and we know
that it's the same tunnel network
because strom finds a big red streak
which we learned the origin of in saw7
when we see the quote-unquote extended
version of gordon's escape from the
bathroom after saw one
like i mentioned earlier this might just
be one of those saw mysteries that can
never be fully explained
forever being discussed in the comments
although i think there is more of a
chance that this location could be
revisited in a future movie so maybe one
day we'll find out
the safe room is also full of easter
eggs and i'm not even talking about that
clown that is basically identical to the
one clown in beverly's house in the 2017
version of it the room contains more of
those chinese figures the pig ornament
from jeff denlin's study and several
wood mannequins a connection to the many
mannequins that john used to test his
traps on dating back to the old stygian
street hideout in an old mannequin
factory
so hoffman's plan at least for now works
j jonah erickson finds strom's phone in
the catacombs at the site of the game
and strom falls victim to the collapsing
walls of the glass coffin trap
at the beginning of this video i
mentioned to the pendulum which is also
the titular device of edgar allan poe's
short story the pit in the pendulum to
bring that connection full circle saw
five's final trap represents
the pit as written by poe himself its
center and of course its great its width
came
just over the yawning golf i shrink back
but the closing walls pressed me
resistlessly onward at length for my
seared and writhing body there was no
longer an inch of foothold on the firm
floor of the prison i struggled no more
but the agony of my soul found vent in
one
loud long and final scream of despair
while this would be the end of strom his
legacy would live on
in the sequel so join me in the next
episode for even more things you missed
in
saw six remember to subscribe to
csworlds for new horrors every week ring
the death bell for
notifications and i'll see you in the
next one assuming
we both survive